(applause and cheering)
Hi. It is 29 minutes
until midnight
when the day resets
and we announce a winner.
But we're all winners here.
I am Chris Hardwick.
So 2016 has been described
by meteorologists
as a "Class 5 (bleep) show,"
so want
to take a break
from the bad news of the world,
courtesy of the adorable news
of the World Wide Web?
Well, let's do it.
Because honestly, you guys,
uh, we have been...
we have been neck deep
in crap news this entire year,
between terrorism and Zika
and the election virus and
losing people,
pop culture icons that we love!
(applause and cheering)
-What the (bleep), 2016?!
What the serious (bleep)?!
So, 2016 has definitely been
the year of no chill.
So we decided that we were gonna
give you a mental break
from all that stuff tonight.
That is this entire show
is just an escape pod
for you emotionally.
Let's start with my sweater.
I feel better surrounded by
fuzzy wuzzy bears, all right?
-(applause and cheering)
-It covers up by boo-boos.
I feel better!
I feel better
when I get stressed out
and I go,
"What am I gonna do?"
And then Alf shows up and goes,
"No problem, Chris."
-(applause and cheering)
-"No problem!”
-Yeah.
-HARDWICK: So...
tonight, everything we're doing
is cuter than a bug's ear,
and a bug's ear
is pretty (bleep) cute.
Welcome to
I Can Haz Midnight.
-Here we are.
-Yeah.
Or Cat Midnight if you want.
(applause and cheering)
All right.
One of the biggest stories
of the election was WikiLeaks,
the hacking organization led
by Julian Assange,
aka Men's rights Sephiroth,
who is possibly aided by Russia
and whose revelations
may have swung the election.
But who gives a (bleep)
about any of that anymore?!
His cat wears a tie! That's what
I care about. Look at that.
-Oh.
-(applause and cheering)
Oh, my God!
He's stuck
in that embassy all these years.
That's probably his best friend
and probable lover.
-We don't know. Could be.
-(audience groaning)
Who would you rather (bleep)--
a human or a cat?
-"It's a tie." Uh...
-Aah!
-Re...
-(applause and cheering)
I know.
Ooh, he's so...
Ha! I kill me!
Comedians, Julian Assange
has spilled a lot
of government secrets.
-What's a secret he might learn
from his cat? -(cat meowing)
-Randy?
-(laughter) -HARDWICK: Oh.
-Okay. Okay. I'm sorry.
-Very nice.
Forgot to mention-- we changed
the buzzers today, so...
Uh, Randy.
Uh, Garfield doesn't
hate Mondays.
He hates Mormons.
It was a typo.
-HARDWICK: Okay, points.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Points.
-(dog barking)
Sara Schaefer.
Uh, three dogs died
in Bone-ghazi.
-HARDWICK: All right. Points.
-(groaning and laughter)
-(duck quacking)
-(laughter)
HARDWICK:
Flula.
Cat ladies aren't
actually lonely.
They are secretly super hot
intercourse machines.
-(laughter)
-Yeah.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Oh. Excuse me.
-(TV news theme plays)
I'm starting to won...
Breaking news.
Reports are coming in now
that there is a dog...
No, not a dog.
I'm sorry.
...a puppy that is threatening
to kill bystanders
with cuteness.
We have to check in
on this going live
to what appears to be
someone's bathroom floor.
Jack, take us there, please.
AUDIENCE:
Aw!
Oh, the humanity.
What a truly adorable moment.
-(laughter) -We will bring you
live, real-time updates
as they come in,
on "Tub Watch '16."
Remember, you heard it here
first on @midnight,
the first and only network brave
enough to bring you "Tub Watch."
-Please stay with us and don't
"paws" your DVRs. -Ah.
-(applause and cheering) -Yeah.
Yeah. -Now back to our regularly
scheduled program.
Next up-- some pigs.
One of the stories captivating
the nation tonight--
two fun Guinea pigs
are sharing a healthy snack.
We take you to the Twitter
video, already in progress.
AUDIENCE:
Aw!
Oh!
-Yeah.
-(applause)
(applause and cheering)
Comedians, your question
about this video--
what's the name
of this hard-core porno?
-(laughter)
-Randy.
Uh, Do Me in a Urine-Soaked Pile
of Newspapers.
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Volume four.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, points.
-(duck quacking)
-Flula.
It's very strange.
-HARDWICK: It is very strange.
-Yeah, yeah. -(laughter)
Two Pigs, One Snack.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-LIEDTKE: Yeah.
-(laughter) -(seal barking)
-Sara Schaefer.
Rabies and the Tramp.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points. Very good.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Good. -Yeah.
Next up-- all dogs go
to college.
All dogs go to college.
Courtesy of the "aw" subreddit,
here's a pup named Boba
who's a certified cutie pie.
That's a good boy!
-Oh!
-(audience sighing)
By the way, that degree took him
28 dog years to get.
Comedians, what was
this collared co-ed's major?
-Oh.
-(kitten mews)
-Randy.
-Dingleberry horticulture.
-All right, points.
(laughter)
-(seal barking)
-Sara.
Psychology with a focus
on emotionally supporting
a fragile white woman
who cannot even.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter)
-Oh. -(applause and cheering)
-(duck quacking)
Flula.
Advanced Resting Bitch Face.
(laughter)
(applause)
Points.
Very sweet. You know what?
Just for fun,
I'm gonna give you guys all each
-100 points because I feel good.
-Oh. -Yes!
-I feel good already.
-(applause and cheering)
Oh.
I'm sorry. I'm just getting
this. Breaking news.
♪ ♪
Now, back
to a "Tub Watch 2016" update.
Updates now. The total count is
now 17 dead from cuteness.
Let's check in with the puppy's
progress and see how he's doing
with that bath live
from the scene.
(audience sighing)
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Mm.
Yeah!
HARDWICK:
Mm.
Not sure what breed that is.
It looks like something
a Muppet baby coughs up
when he chokes on cotton candy,
but it is (bleep) adorable.
Comedians, this puppy is
permed and dangerous.
I would like you to give me
an eyewitness description
of the perp so that people
can be on the lookout.
(duck quacking)
Flula.
Oh, it looks like a deer
has pooped on a cloud.
-Yes. It does, yeah.
-(laughter)
Points. Yeah, these look...
these are little poops.
Little poops.
Tiny deer poo-poos.
Aw, that is adorable.
Aren't you guys feeling better
already about the world?
-(cheering) -Knowing
that this stuff's out there.
Aw...
That is the end
of Rapid Refresh.
Let's check in
with the scoreboards.
With 600 adorable pink points,
his new album Animalbum
is now available on iTunes--
Flula Borg is back on the show.
(cheering)
And with 600 star points,
her new digital series
Woman Online is coming soon
to Seriously.TV,
Sara Schaefer!
(cheering)
And... with 500 sparkle points,
performing at Doc's Lab
in San Francisco November 21,
Randy Liedtke!
(cheering)
And now (bleep) the world
while it burns.
-It's time for tonight's
#HashtagWars. -Yeah!
(cheering)
HARDWICK:
Aw...
Guys, what's cuter than cats?
Baby cats!
That's what's cuter than...
-(audience aw'ing)
-I know! An audible gasp!
From a woman in the audience
who had never seen
a cat in baby form before.
They're called kittens.
That's what we call them, ma'am.
Uh, and since
we're fully committed
to keeping this episode
as cute as possible,
tonight's hashtag is #CatTV.
Examples might be--
Paw & Order.
Aw...
The theme song is...
♪ Meow, meow. ♪
♪ Meow-meow, meow, meow ♪
♪ Meow-meow-meow, meow, meow ♪
♪ Meow! Meow! Meow! Meow! ♪
♪ Meow, meow. ♪
(laughter, applause)
-♪ Meow, meow, meow, meow ♪
♪ Meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow... ♪
Also, I have 60 seconds for you
on the clock, and begin.
-(cat meows)
-Randy Liedtke.
-Downton Tabby.
-Yes, points!
-(seal barking)
-Sara Schaefer.
-Sex and the Kitty.
-Points.
-(duck quacking) -Flula.
-Desperate House Cats.
-Yes, points.
-(seal barking)
-Sara. -Who Wants to Be
a Meow-lionaire?
-Points.
-(cat meows)
-Randy.
-Litter Box on the Prairie.
-Points.
-(seal barking)
-Sara.
-Eastbound & Put Down.
-Points. Points. Points.
-(audience groaning) -(meow)
-Flula.
-(duck quacking)
-Meow-dur, She Wrote.
-Points. Very good.
(cat meows)
-Randy.
-Scared by the Bell.
-All right, points.
-(cat meows)
-Randy.
-Mouse. Instead of House.
-Yeah, yeah, points.
-(laughter)
-(cheering, whooping)
-(duck quacking)
-Flula.
-Two and a Half Men
Who Are Also Allergic to Cats.
-(laughter)
-All right, points. Very good.
Very good. That is the end
of the #HashtagWars.
Please send us
your hashtag #CatTV
and tag those @midnight to keep
this adorable train going.
We'll be right back
with more Catnip Night.
Our tweet of the day
from last night's #HashtagWar
was sent to us by @auntiem1977.